welcome to this video playing card stud
can't start from Estonia right estonia
does this guy he does not have named him
although he has a name you recruit
Penske okay let's see um ok we have a v6
type of opening I should have taken
really hmm ok send up the greatest pawn
structure ever but it ok it's not soft
like terrible in one night a 67 to e6
this kind of this kind of idea ok ma'am
if he he might go for herbs for a
quickie f porn push but it does not look
like it he has played rookie one ok see
what is he trying to do wish away three
maybe no okay it's not not a big deal no
sea forces idea I don't know if he takes
a diary capture yep okay let's not think
about it for too long a five ok now I
can really fight for the light squares
no we just wants to close down the whole
thing ok ok so I've got less space that
much is clear let's do this if he takes
Bishop takes at least I have some play
against the form
if it's not taking then I really don't
have any problems I mean okay yeah no no
I'm just just totally fine no I'm better
definitely if he allows all this stuff
but it's not it's nothing totally
serious not yet at least so he wants to
play a form should I am prevent it with
playing F for myself if he goes a for
the whole thing will be very close but
FYI can take and just straight trade
stuff
yeah this is hey this isn't what I meant
with very closed
yeah invasion invasion or up [ __ ] I'm
not sure about the moon water yeah rook
edge to would be nice to get in
we are difficult to avoid that in the
long run
I could have just taken the night ah
what did I what am i doing and I was
very much focused of course on improving
the position or grade but he just
blundered the night in one move ah and I
mean oh wow yeah this sometimes happens
when you're so focused on little
maneuvers and stuff here then you you
overlook very very simple things okay
maybe I can get in queen age too
or h1 not sure this looks ok but what
now says some way to to get more my
light pieces here involved like here
nigerianigeria takes and yeah this could
work yeah 95 takes Bishop takes Queen
hangs now let's go for that come on if
it's not working what can I do I could
have taken his night and the thing would
have been over already
on e6 I go 90 for some sort of
disturbing move
yeah night coming to a form that is good
I also don't see move him yeah I just I
just go here and ignore the whole thing
the bishop is the bishop is stopping the
pawn very reliably check yeah the
position is very close but I can either
go to h5 and put the bishop here simply
to to break through check oh the g one g
point is doing the home run you can
slide there's i can still go to d3 and
just freshmen just taken the night yeah
well around here white is better because
of the the space advantage but he have
to f5 here he has to take I mean
absolutely if he's not taking then yeah
I don't know I mean I'm not saying that
I'm in terrible shape here but if he
wants to do something in the game he has
to take and after this I'm totally fine
and after you gave me this even with the
tempo I'm of course just just better
here because I have the space advantage
on the on the Kings side and I'm
basically the one determining what the
pawn structure would be like so just get
more stuff there it's really funny that
stock Fisher thinks that this is equal
yeah maybe it's equal because I cannot
breakthrough but work awesome it's
always black with the idea
the idea it's not clear from the ever
can be something serious but he just
blundered this night here I can just
take the night and totally totally silly
yeah now I'm okay yeah that was here was
night here here there was this move
which I didn't see winning okay yeah I
prepared this 95 and it was night g5
with minus 7 now this is quite ok ok so
it was nice to have this shot at the end
after I had just had refused to to take
the take the piece the night ok hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching